Oh welcome to another Roddick li charged
episode of what's in the box on Power
Man Iron Fist that's right the two of us
heroes have been hired Iron Fist the
[ __ ] out of this box open it up let's
find out what's going on inside my
friend what's in the box what's in the
box
whoa
I sense a theme kids
all right check it out false what we're
looking at today is the Funko pop Civil
War series or at least a few of them
this one is the Jada Toys diecast
diecast why that's the most expensive
cast toy there is little less enthused
about these than that we're what we're
all excited about these well there it is
different strokes for different folks
why because the metal my lord
I think it's Marxist I stab the Hot
Wheels cars so every time you see metal
like this reminds me of a happy
childhood plastic reminds me of a
[ __ ] happy childhood and a happy
adulthood cuz I have a flashlight this
all has something to do with Civil War
kids civil war latest motion picture
that the good folks of Marvel have
blessed us with they do the most
important thing there can be make great
comic book movies and this looks to be
no exception
let's dig into the toys man yeah you
clearly want to open those I want to
open up that Black Panther diecast metal
100% metal with heavy grade iron Jada
Toys higher this guy right now there's
your voice Funko pop aside from being
like the must-have thing toy what would
you call this action non action figure
in action figure everybody's got these
man everybody wants even these they tie
in real - oh my god I so they're getting
points take it off right away Jada first
because look at the fun of Funko pop
comes right out of the packaging we got
fast that was I'm having a good time oh
my god I've already had three adventures
be fair that does look kind of cool
though I mean not as nice as the Funko
pop like the oversized head is a little
freakish but not cute ish like this kind
of looks like Hello Kitty yes and you
know this looks like Hello cable you
could actually pet play with that though
you can't play with this you would kill
a child of this if you gave this to your
baby and that baby was playing with
another baby ah
into the head man like literally what
I'm gonna bring it to my baby I can't
doesn't metal scream old-timey
like metal is like train sets and
[ __ ] rosebuds plastic is our
childhood man Star Wars GI Joe there's
been plastic throughout my entire
childhood one-way plastic plastics dummy
plastic all right I've only gotten one
out so far well you know what you've
gotten three out I'll bet you I get
these so this line is the Civil War
bobble head line yes look at them all
nodding did you guys like the movie oh
yeah oh look I heard II oh it broke Wow
like it's two medals they're saying it's
cool they're made of solid diecast metal
with only slight articulation at the
hips let's see the articulation oh you
ain't kidding slight man I feel like
there it's like if you can bend metal
then it's articulate yeah there is no
spoon they each weigh about half a pound
which would you say is the heavier the
Black Panther mmm
say someone could have got killed
I'm saying by Panther you're wrong
Captain America is the heaviest one
comes in at just under a pound alright
so in in AB line of Funko pop they also
got others other than ones we so
obviously we know that is uh Will Smith
Fresh Prince oh my god Arius kilt on the
years has not Will Smith Anthony Mackie
that's my man playing the Falcon
oh yeah that's a no right here you have
that very famous character I got a look
it's 13 you didn't know I knew that she
was in Captain America she's a lady who
was next door to capture spying on the
first and then he was there laundry
you're welcome to use my machine oh yeah
what's it cost cup coffee you want to
cover that one and then at the end she
like when Robert Redford when a Sundance
Kid was like freeze [ __ ]
I'm just making the dialogue up she
jumped up and was like not on my watch
captain's orders
choo choo they're gonna be all a one
agent 13 the immortal character why you
go to agent 13 I'm a hate to be this guy
but like where's spider-man ordering hey
everyone where's ant-man I know you know
a lot of super people so thanks for
thinking of me
I'm right here there's spoiler on this
body giant man Oh apparently giant man
makes him look at this if I cover up
those two letters on Giant Man what's it
say ant-man die just break your brain
right this is awesome
Captain America I know you too you're
great of course it is the Scarlet Witch
this is the Olsen girl the one that's
not a twin
put the [ __ ] cross oh that's an Olsen
older sister you mean that broke your
brain more than giant-man waily waily so
the Olsen twins a trunk full house had a
baby
Hut and it was this girl and a call and
it comes with two clones can never be
trusted there are all sins all over the
place
well this has got to be a war machine
what is that it's like a paddle in this
it's like thank you sir may I have
enough thank you sir I don't know what
that is man maybe that's what the Civil
War is about I've been reading some
awards
it's what the new one in comics the
whole books I'm reading all of them
well like about the real American Civil
War you'll and I read that too little
boring bizarre men don't show up till
then oh my god that robert e lee do you
read this digitally of it yeah you're
buying it online drink oh yeah it's
great that to the kids that don't make
it by comics not murdered by comics on
your iPads and tablets and such things
and why not Marvel source material is
important kids comic books read them
even if it isn't here iPad hey we get
another opportunity is the knife which
is always thrilling here on the show big
boys now we're back in the land a living
action figures look at this fine
assortment right here it's kind of tied
into Civil War I see three Civil War
figures here but they've also used this
opportunity to sandwich in some other
figures that maybe wouldn't be as
popular there's giant man's body yep so
all this line has lagged leg torso head
leg arm and [ __ ] here's your Avengers
let's talk about this nuke yeah who is
in the comics Frank Miller's immortal
run of daredevil and they also used him
in Jessica Jones the Netflix series but
he didn't face paint I'm happy to see a
nuke figure though look how armed he is
arms in the teeth a few will and very
very patriotic this is the Donald Trump
action figure right here right here this
guy is called Red Guardian I believe he
is the Soviet Union version he's the
Yakov Smirnoff of Captain America what a
country this may be unfamiliar to
everybody who loves these Marvel movies
like who's that old man this is old
useless white Nick Fury insubordination
incitement to mutiny David Hasselhoff
himself at one point played Nick Fury in
the TV movie I believe it was you forgot
one
attempted grievous bodily harm when they
did the ultimates line of the comics and
introduced Nick Fury
they drew him as Sam Jackson this long
before they were mega Marvel movies but
they were like we are gonna make movies
one day and we wanted to be Sam Jackson
and [ __ ] goddamn a thing get Sam
Jackson dream that's the moral of that
story point and dream put this [ __ ]
thing together in order to get you to
buy all of them they put one piece of
each of that'll become one giant figure
I think you should be bigger what I
think oh look at they make them level to
the right don't make me do it
you weren't protesting nearly as hard as
that you're like oh don't make me die
for no worthy performance boiler from
the movies look at this black panther
we're living in a world where black
panthers collude and you could do you
can move his torso so you could do that
we're living in a world where we get to
see as many black panther figures want
we're gonna see him in a movie
Hey it never ends on this show guy man
down all right man cut into this [ __ ]
actions like that you don't even bother
to cut the rest of tape ah the gun shows
in town ladies a joke maybe there is a
gun show cuz Eisen cuz Isaac looks like
oh yeah what is it as much fun as this
cuz those kiddin this is pretty badass
man backs off to the good folks ass bro
for not just doing [ __ ] action
figures but letting you be part of the
fun you could rather than play Captain
America be Captain America may made
Captain America Danny I'm a [ __ ] may
make make it make it
I hope I'm supposed to break this
plastic pieces off if you [ __ ] this up
because seriously it's gonna be Civil
War you're a [ __ ] Iron Man and I'm
care I'm gonna have my land of iron and
you got the land of blue Sun in there
civil war war zones what go ahead what
the fight continues an Iron Man has his
own land
it's called Aaron and then Captain
America has blue Oh cuz I didn't wear
this [ __ ] son
how's it
my god oh [ __ ] I'm on fire
oh my god I meant to [ __ ] do this
watch this [ __ ] son alright this action
who is it okay Avengers Assemble there
it is man good times right here in the
middle of it look at all these fabulous
prizes man Marvel Civil War is a bounty
all over your face neck and chest won't
stop giving don't play with that nobody
cares I am put that down
Hawkeye waste of time but none of this
is a waste of time this was fun these
are cool look out there there it is
folks we looked in the box we found a
bunch of Marvel man you want to see us
pull other things out of the box perhaps
more figures from the world of Civil War
that didn't show up in this line a
Spider Man hinted let us know right to
the screen junkies at this address below
is on Twitter or on Facebook if you see
the screen junkies in this street scream
at them tell those [ __ ] has been
stabbed all orange take [ __ ] out in a
box or write a pleasant email either way
let us know what you want to see man is
that's what we do here on the what's in
the boxes just pull dreams out of
cardboard man for what's in the box
Jesus Christ Wow sorry I'm Kevin Smith
Casey be you uh and what's in the box
this week has been just more
[Music]